عن جمله هذه الملفات المطروحه في قمه بالي
معنا منبال سامويل وير بيرجع متحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكي لنبدا بما يتعلق بحرب
اوكرانيا وتحديدا ما يتعلق بروسيا كان
هناك كلام عن بيان متشدد حياله روسيا ثم
كان هناك كلام عن صيغه توافقيه كما قال
وزير الخارجيه الروسي ماذا عنكم ما يتعلق
بواشنطن بصيغه هذا البيان
اذا مساء الخير
من جانبنا من الورده المتحده لدينا النصر
الموقف تجاه هذه الحرب بدون اي تبرير التي
يشمها رئيس قوته منذ تقريبا ثمان شهور
كل يوم على امن الغذاء
بتاعه
والتعاون والتنسيق مع الدول الاخرى هنا في
هذه
القمه
الاخرى ولكن في نهايه المقاطع
وعندما هو يقوم بسهب قوته من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اذا نعم نحن نبذه لكل في
وسائلنا اللي همم لوصول الى بيان مشترك
بين كل هذه الدوله هنا في مجموعه العشرين
ولكن في نهايه المطاف نهايه هذه الحرب لن
ياتي عبر اي بيان طيب من وين بدك تقول
للمجتمع الدولي الصين موقفه واضح هي ضد
سياسه عازل روسيا عن هذه القمه قمه ال20
البيان او الولايات المتحده او اي دوله
اخرى التي تقوم بعزل الروسيه لا الان
عندما ندخل في العين الكبار مثلا التصويت
المقرر في المتكرر في جميع الامه في الامم
المتحده عندما نرى كيف همم اكثر من الف
شركه خاصه من كل انها العالم غادرت من
الروسيه عندما اعتبار العقوبات التي فرضت
على الروسيه ليس فقط من جانب الامريكي
ولكن
المتحده او اي دوله اخرى التي همم
طيب ايضا نقطه تامه في هذه القمه واللقاء
الذي جرى بين الرئيس الامريكي وكذلك
التركي في ما يتعلق باتفاق الحبوب الكل
ينتظر فتره الاتفاق سوف تنتهي والكل ينتظر
عن مصير هذا الاتفاق ان كان سيتم تمديده
او تجديده ام لا
الولايات المتحده تدعم تجديد هذه
المبادرات
القمح في البحر الاسود وفعلا ال ال ال
الضوء والانسان متضرر من عدم تجديد هذا
اتفاق ليس الاوكرانيين او الروس او
المتحده لا الدوله
الفقيره والفقراء في الكون انها العالم
همم
بسبب هذه الحرب الوحشيه الروسيه
الى تجديد هذه الاتفاق
شكرا لكم
متحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكي